i heard this i don't know if this is
true i think it is there's no rule
keeping women out of the nfl or the nba
or the mlb
yes that's a common misconception is
that these leagues are male
only leagues but they're actually open
to anyone who wants to be in them
so in fact they don't have any females
so they're sexist
yeah they're keeping the women on
purpose anybody we've seen some women
try and compete in
the nfl like to try out for it i should
say as kickers and there's been a couple
i think we've gotten close
but there's no women in major league
sports even though it's open to them
yeah i mean it's the gap is so huge and
it's all part of the the push to get
trans athletes
or to get males to be able to compete
against females it all
comes back to the language game they
play which is actually the most
horrifying part because they've realized
that you don't actually need to change
laws
in order to get them uh uh
i guess expressed differently uh
enforced differently if you just change
the language
exactly so we have leagues like the wnba
or women's
women's sports women's categories but if
you define redefine what a woman is to
be not adult human female but to be
anyone who identifies as a woman
then all of a sudden you can have people
saying you know and if you're chaining
the mantra that trans women are women
full stop then well why can't a trans
woman play
in the women's category so we need to
try to say
call what we should be doing is calling
them female sports uh but then of course
they'll come after the word female
they are i mean they are yeah biological
sex doesn't exist
they've been saying that for years now
and they'll point to overlap between
males and females saying that like not
every
you know some females can compete
against some males i said well we're
talking about
the elite of elite athletes we're not
talking about
the center of the bell curves where
there's some overlapping ability if
we're sampling the
0.01 percent of elite athletes it's
entirely dominated by males yeah this is
this is something really interesting
that i had talked about before
in terms of like why don't we see women
at the top of like ceo positions
or in in major league sports and things
like that the
the the there's a bunch of sports i
should
well you know intelligence-based like
strategic games games like chess
obviously
and you don't see a lot of women at the
top of these things and
there's are you familiar with the you
probably are the greater male
variability hypothesis
yeah so there are there are more male
idiots and more male geniuses
and women tend to be closer to average
so if that's true
that means you got a ton of really dumb
guys and that's unfortunate for those
guys and for the women have to deal with
them
but then you also have a a certain uh
a certain factor more of genius men
versus genus women
so then if you have i don't know don't
know what the proportion is to you know
how many
do you actually do know how many genius
men to jeans and women i'm not sure
but i know as you get further to the you
know tail ends of the distribution that
the proportion
of male to female goes and goes up yeah
it's rather extreme
yet the uh so it was interesting because
based on the greater male
variability hypothesis there are more
women than men who are average
of average capability intelligence and
which i was also reading another study
was very interesting
sat scores align similarly
to the greater male variability
hypothesis in terms of intelligence
so if you have for every eight male
geniuses two female geniuses then don't
be surprised if you have 80 male ceos
and 20 females
or even less because what happens is if
you have
a million people now you're getting dis
it's it's just disproportionately
becoming more and more male geniuses
that have to compete
for the same space and it's just harder
for everybody
but if you look at our our society with
328 million people
and whatever the proportion is let's say
you have you know 10 million geniuses
and only a million are female that means
a woman
has an a one out of 10 chance of getting
that
job which means more often than not
won't get it and you'll see a lot more
men as ceos a lot more men
in in higher ranking positions in
general yeah and this is what the
the whole diversity equity and inclusion
is trying to
undermine basically because they just
look at the the outcomes
the dis disparate outcomes that we have
and they assume that there must be some
structural
problem they're keeping females out of
these certain fields
because everything's a social construct
therefore yes i mean that's
that's where they're coming from um we
have this concept in science you've
almost
certainly heard it that correlation
doesn't equal causation we're taught
that first you know first
day of of intro bio or intro science
class
but something that's not really taught
that should be is that disparity does
not equal discrimination that's you know
thomas soul right there that needs to be
something that is just ingrained in us
because
if you just look at the different
backgrounds of of certain white
americans like
french americans versus russian
americans you have
differences in their average income
that's it's pretty large
are we really going to say that there's
like some structural discrimination
against
you're just a freshman americans and
things like that so yeah so
russian russophobia we need to look at
what's what i call this like a
multivariate analysis whenever you're
looking
at the differences in outcomes you can't
just stop at the difference of outcome
you need to go and
look at other variables how many
individuals are
majoring in this in school how many you
know if are there differences in just
preferences going up once you control
for these variables
uh you usually find out that well the
disparity at the end is kind of what we
would predict based on
you know sex-related proclivities and um
it's just randomness i mean randomness
can produce unequal outcomes
all the time get like a random number
generator it's going to give you a
different number
every time you do it so so uh in
you made an interesting point about you
know france versus russia
and i remember reading something
interesting about france you know they
smoke a lot
i don't know if they smoke as much as
they used to but that was like a trope
and they drink a lot of red wine
as does italy and there are studies that
track them and found
lower rates of say like heart disease or
things like that and i wonder if
you know these things are typically
associated with being bad for you
you know drinking too much alcohol i
wonder if there's certain
characteristics that are developed over
time
in different you know uh cultures or i
guess
what would you call it like the the
french people meaning that they
they have over time developed certain
characteristics
based on genetics you know what i'm
trying to say like that red wine might
benefit people of france but not people
of say
south korea is that is that a
possibility so like an actual genetic
evolution that's creating these
like that's not just a cultural
difference maybe right yeah yeah
so uh one example is i've often been
told
that i don't do dairy well because i'm
part korean and south
and and southeast asians didn't have a
lot of dairy in their diet
so they did not so so they're less
likely to produce the lactase enzyme
yeah yeah i would say that there's
definitely some like human
diversity that's of that nature um
it's hard to know if it could go back as
recent as like wine drinking or
something like that because
it's pretty new and it have to take a
lot there'd be some some directional
selection for that to be
yeah those types of cultural differences
but i do think one thing that we need to
be focusing on
that a lot of people don't like to talk
about is cultural differences that can
create these different outcomes and
different preferences with individuals
and populations
want to want to do in their lives i mean
you do get
i mean some stereotypes are on average
true to some degree i know a lot of
people who had asian backgrounds and
their families are very much
focused on education it's a cultural
thing yeah i can't tell you how many
black friends that i've had who've told
me that when they're growing up they're
interested in going into
into stem they all have the exact same
story
they were told that they're acting white
they were made fun of they were
discouraged from going
into these fields and i think that's
something that
they don't allow us to talk about these
cultural differences
but they absolutely matter and i think
that that is something needs to be put
on the table but they don't want on the
table because that's sort of
seen as putting blame on the groups that
are
that are doing this but it's you can't
look past that
i heard i i read this somewhere maybe
it's not true that uh
there's a disproportionate amount of
asian doctors and
i think that's true yeah have you heard
that what's that a disproportionate
amount of asian doctors i believe this
to be the case
and i do not believe that is because of
uh what is it called
racism no it's not benevolent racism no
no yeah yeah it's benevolent racism
where they accept more of them because
they're smarter
no do you know what it's called um
affirmative action oh yeah yeah
yeah right well no affirmative action
seems to actually be a detriment to
asian people but i i think you know it's
really funny
um i i love this joke i was talking to
some friends and i mentioned
we were talking about youtube
demonetization you know all the channels
are getting their
little yellow icons you can't make money
anymore and there was a big trend where
people are like it's political
you know they're censoring you know
people challenging the establishment and
i was talking to a friend and i said i
don't think that's true because my mom
makes math videos
and her math videos get demonetized and
then one friend said i think it's funny
that your mom your korean mom does math
tutorial videos
and i immediately started laughing i
thought it was hilarious and i texted
her right away like
and she laughed too because it is funny
and i'm like how did that happen like
what are you doing
it's just i don't know uh it's it's
remnants of
uh of the culture i think that mattered
and to
my mom it was it was it was cultural
there's no like genetic predisposition
to be like go study i think it came from
you know her her parents and their
parents before her parents and things
like that
and that carries on and has a huge
impact on me because then i grew up with
pam with with a mom who was like i'm
going to teach you how to do all these
things very early and you're going to be
really good at math
and it really did help and then i
stopped going to high school and started
focusing more on like
human and social behavior stuff and i
did non-profit fundraising for
you know uh for various nonprofits
obviously i think it's actually
encouraging to know that
something like culture could be playing
such a big role because culture changes
it changes very quickly you know it'd be
much worse situation if
these were actually due to you know
fundamental biological differences
between certain ethnic groups
that would be a terrible situation to be
in uh
you know i know that's not true not the
case because i had a bunch of asian
friends growing up who are potheads who
couldn't add two plus two
dumb as a box of rocks and i'm like that
proves it to me it's not race
they're just lay about stoners and
people who choose to do hard work can
succeed
that's actually kind of encouraging to
me because my take on the cultural
differences is that
you can't change culture like you can't
involuntarily change
it i guess it has to be something that
people do for themselves
so it's always kind of deject caused me
to be a little bit dejected about it
because i'm like how do you change what
people
think and how they view things like it's
gonna be a generational
thing i mean the culture is not gonna
you can't just like to have someone give
up their culture so it's gonna be a
generational thing
but at least it's a faster than other
processes that could be happening so
that's why i think these far leftists
are actually
fascistic nazi-esque types i'm being i'm
exaggerating a little bit but what i
mean is
the the end result of what they're doing
is the preservation of
individual in cultures like you can't
wear someone else's
robe or whatever right you wear the
wrong or the chinese dress
canceler you can't do it's not allowed
dreadlocks no you gotta go
and so what they're doing is with
segregation they're also doing cultural
enforcement
everybody must remain the perfect
stereotype of their culture
based on the color of their skin and
that is the way it will always be
and they'll even create white only
spaces you know what's going to what's
actually going to change
the discrimination and bring people
together is literally people just living
near each other and sharing in each
other's culture
we've been doing that for a long time
it's been kind of awesome you know we
can we can have movies where you have
different people playing different
you know uh characters different
backgrounds you can have
white people you know dressing up in
ninja outfits and
whatever and it was just like you know
whatever we we we share and we exchange
culture
and now it's all being reversed yeah
they allow the cultures to bleed
one direction you know like other
marginalized
communities can take on the culture of
you know
quote dominant groups right but the
whole
field of like post-colonial theory this
is what uh
keeps them from allowing white
individuals or anyone from a dominant
white western male whatever
uh background to appropriate culture
that's why cultural appropriation is
considered such a
a taboo thing because it's basically
taking the voice away from
uh colonel people who've been colonized
basically
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you